you know how you go to a nice bar and
they have like an ice program where they
got big ice and little ice and it's
clear and it's beautiful presentational
you're thinking yourself I got to do
that I got to do that at home that's
what the studios need ice kit is it
comes with this rig which you pour water
into and then freeze the reason that ice
is not clear is that it has little
impurities that nucleate you get the
kind of clouds inside it so this thing
is supposed to let those some of those
nucleation sites settle okay boom using
the kits chisel and mallet you're
supposed to split the ice into meat
cubes
how I almost had it but let's just say
you were like stranded in the middle of
nowhere with nothing nothing but this
$80 ice kit and perhaps some bourbon and
vermouth and maybe a little bitter you
wouldn't want to take out a nice glass
well how would you even have such a
thing unless you're one of these this is
beautiful right now but you're worried
thinking oh my god that's gonna break
what happens to be drops alike oh look
at that nothing at all because this this
is a Snow Peak rocks tumbler $25 look at
that it just wants whiskey that's all it
wants good whiskey fortunately I can
help
that's what I mean by these shards they
actually look really nice
emergency Manhattan bourbon for moose
bitters watch this that is how you solve
an emergency